ich verstehe jetzt gar nichts mehr bist
du betrunken
hey leute was klappt willkommen beim
neuen video wie es wahrscheinlich schon
hier hätten dann seht ich habe eine neue
perspektive und ich frage mich gerade ob
ich das noch höher stellen sollte egal
fürs heutige video last mir dass du ihr
könnt ja mal schreiben was haltet ihr
von meinem neuen hintergrund schreibt es
auf jeden fall in die kommentare
interessiert mich brennend sagt mir dass
für retouren und ob ich das jetzt noch
ein bisschen höher stellen soll könnt
ihr auch meine kommentare schreiben
oder findet ihr die perspektive so super
klar ich finde man sieht dass hier die
softbox im fernseher weil hier ist es
hell und irgendwie müsst ihr mich
ansehen
das sieht doch leicht scheiße aus aber
das ist halt so schmecken soll ich
machen ansonsten gefällt mir das
allerdings ziemlich gut so es ist alles
schön hell ihr könnt nicht gut sehen
hoffe ich und wir kommen auf sofort auf
den punkt und zwar kam er am letzten
donnerstag keine ahnung ich glaube das
war donnerstag auf jeden fall kam ja ja
der oddset prangt an meine freundin und
der war schlecht er war schlecht alex
offen zu der war richtig stellen aber
irgendwie hab jetzt trotzdem gefeiert
und ich hab mir gesagt bei 15.000 likes
mache ich das nochmal bei irgendeiner
person und ihr habt natürlich locker
geschafft deswegen würde ich hier direkt
mal anmerken bei 15.000 likes kommt auch
ein dritter parteien irgend eine
x-beliebige person da muss ich
allerdings irgendwann finden der das
noch nicht kennt weil das kenne jetzt
schon ziemlich viele naja soll schon
schaffen auf jeden fall okay ich muss
mich auch erst mal heute steigern wenn
ihr heute mit meiner leistung zufrieden
seid dann können natürlich im dritten
part verlangen wenn es wieder scheiße
wird dann lasse ich das einfach und
heute habe ich mir eine person
ausgesucht die das wirklich auf keinen
fall kennen sollte
obwohl um ehrlich zu sein ich weiß es
nicht die guckt mittlerweile wegen mir
auch schon andere und youtube naja erbte
wahrscheinlich am titel und auch schon
gelesen
seit wann ist ein ziemlich unten ich
mach das ganze heute bei meiner mutter
danke schön danke
ja und ich habe wirklich weit ein lied
rausgesucht bzw
andrack den ich mega feier und er auch
mega gut dazu passt der passt heftig und
zwar geht es da drin so um ja bei mir
läuft nicht mehr so auf youtube ich
brauche mehr klicks und meine eltern
sagen schon immer so ja alex youtube
weiße so das ist nichts festes was ist
das eigentlich für ein job so die nehmen
das zwar mittlerweile schon ernst aber
ich muss natürlich auch irgendwas festes
in der hand haben ist ja logisch sich
auch selber so eigentlich und deswegen
will ich auch gar nicht lange lagern und
wir fangen sofort man mit dem song von
whd und energie
hallo
die antwortet wenigstens sofort und
jetzt passt auch jetzt geht es richtig
los
wie kommst du denn jetzt darauf läuft es
nicht mehr so gut die sache ist
mittlerweile weiß sie sogar was klick
sind das muss ich erstmal noch erklären
aber mittlerweile verstehe ich nicht
dazu noch der rote frei ja man nicht
mache klick beiträgt roter pfeil und was
ist ein klick bild der die das cliq bild
er die das cliq bild wie sagt man das
überhaupt das cliq dating doch der klick
baic war keine ahnung
na ja ich würde sagen wir machen weiter
ist alles okay mit dir muss ich mir
sorgen machen
das finde ich liebe das ist schön dass
so was nächste muss sie jetzt auf meinen
eigenen songs beziehen weil sonst macht
das keinen sinn und den song kennt sie
nämlich das weiß ich weiß war ein schock
ich war da nicht mehr helfen
jetzt kommt das beste ich verstehe jetzt
gar nichts mehr
bist du betrunken hey wir haben doch
mitten am tag
okay leute wir machen natürlich weiter
du hast 106 mehr ich hab wundert ist
dass viel scheiße mann mein letztes
video wurde fortan fällt doch dass ich
sie wird besser mit hinten auf jetzt
könnte ich richtig klasse
ok warte mal ich habe jetzt mal besser
frauen geschrieben wir müssen ja auch
irgendwo anders niveau denken samt was
mail ist das anzeige bild von einem
video ist zu oft mein video weil ich
interessant weil du mein sohn bist ich
bin auch sonst aus dem alter raus okay
jetzt müssen wir das ganze natürlich
irgendwie beenden
und zwar
nicht wichtig
siehst du das licht nicht worauf du dich
okay dabei belassen wir den quatsch es
auch okay um ehrlich zu sein finde ich
das reicht jetzt ich schreibe jetzt
irgendwie so ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ich
hab dich reingelegt immer besser ja
leute ich finde ich war gut oder
seit mir ehrlich ich finde das ist mit
viel besser gelungen als bei dem letzten
part wenn ihr noch nicht gesehen habt
ganz oben in der video beschreibung
verlinkt ist auf jeden fall auch ab und
lass mir auf jeden fall die daumen nach
oben daten kommentar wenn ihr meint ich
habe mich gesteigert und in of warcraft
auf dem dritten part da mache ich das
auf jeden fall ansonsten ist selbst als
einbinden wir sehen uns dienstag wieder
beim neuen video um 18 uhr einschalten
nicht vergessen
und heute sind meine haare nicht schön
muss jetzt noch sein
hard rain